hi it's me you may be wondering to
yourself where am I or where am ii not
you me where is markiplier right now and
you may be also wondering why am i
leaving on the bed is too weird angle
none of that is important right now I've
got some information to tell you and I
only know one way to do it properly with
stock footage my day started like any
other I woke up early before the crack
of dawn got has been showered brushing
the keys and then I realized that today
was the day on my calendar it said the
day that it was was today and no other
day so I packed my bags and then flew
out the door free of the bird fresh of
the flowing river why
and then I hopped on a plane crammed the
back seats I sweep to my destination of
place where I am where you're wondering
where I am right now that's late
something so horrible that I can't
actually tell you but the smarter among
you may already know where I am
it rhymes with many schwab a back toe
and while I'm here I'm going to be
making different videos here where I am
you'll see them in your eyes or on your
television or on your mobile device but
I'm also going to be going on another
adventure along here the untold lands
are in the way and there knows what kind
of fate with dragons I play
[Music]
yeah I'm in Boston um
so here four packs and